bonjour
bienvenue au zoo de thoiry en cette
chaude journée
vous allez voir qu'il fait quand même
assez bon sur le parc on a la chance
d'avoir un parc très arboré et puis je
vais vous emmener voir un petit peu ce
qu'on fait pour aider nos animaux par
ces fortes chaleurs
[Musique]
alors on va se rendre au magasin c'est
l'endroit où on entrepose la nourriture
pour tous les animaux du parc et on va
aller récupérer des glaçons on va
distribuer au maki catta c'est
dégueulasse on en fait c'est qu'on a
fait nous mêmes on a rempli des gobelets
avec de l'eau et à l'intérieur on a mis
des fruits et des légumes et celle du
tout vous le fait tous les jours en
période de canicule alors pas tous les
jours non parce qu'en fait ça reste un
faut que ça reste un petit plaisir pour
l'animal une petite surprise on appelle
ça un enrichissement donc si c'est tous
les jours ça n'est plus ça n'est plus
une surprise
[Musique]
je vais aller chercher les glaçons au
congélateur
[Musique]
on a différents types de glaçons j'ai
pris vraiment que des glaçons qui
ponctionne des fruits et des légumes
puisqu'on va aller les données ou le
lémurien mais on peut aussi des
coiffeurs relation avec de la viande à
l'intérieur par exemple
du sort pour les quartiers en fête idée
gassion avec des insectes pour les
omnivores nous sommes des insectes voilà
donc là on va avoir de la poire de la
pomme peu de fraises du melon
différents fruits ça va leur faire
plaisir
[Musique]
donc là on est aux lémurs trek donc la
zone immersive où on peut venir voir les
lémuriens et en particulier les makis
cattas qu'ils étaient tous posé à long
mais qui ont vu arriver avec montceau
donc ils savent que c'est pour eux du
coup ils sont venu à ma rencontre
ils attendent les fruits les plus sucrés
forcément sont les plus appréciées
globalement les végétariens général on
donne pas trop trop de fruits parce que
c'est surtout les fruits qu'on mange
nous les humains ils sont beaucoup trop
sucrés pour les animaux du coup vivent
principalement des légumes un petit peu
plus de temps en temps aussi mais c'est
sûr que du coup quand on leur amène les
glaçons plein de fruits c'est vraiment
le grand plaisir
[Musique]
donc les glaçons c'est ce qu'on appelle
à un enrichissement c'est quelque chose
qu'on va pouvoir amener dans
l'environnement l'animal qui va sortir
de son quotidien qui du coup va pouvoir
le distraire le surprendre et l'occupé
aussi par exemple sur le glaçon il va
devoir les chais longtemps avant de
pouvoir atteindre le fruit plutôt que
d'avoir directement la nourriture
distribuée de manger directement ça les
occupe il ya différentes formes
d'enrichissement donc alimentaires comme
la avec la glace on peut aussi parfois
par exemple cacher la nourriture il peut
y avoir aussi des envies richement
olfactif on va mettre des odeurs
particulières qui vont stimuler un petit
peu les animaux l'effet recherché vous
avez l'environnement aussi qui peut être
en lui-même un enrichissement quand on
ajoute des balançoires par exemple pour
les pour les primates les points d'eau
sont eux mêmes des enrichissements les
animaux pouvant aller jouer dans l'eau
par exemple donc tout ça ça va permettre
vraiment de distraire l'animal de
l'occuper sur sa journée
[Musique]
comme quoi j'ai terminé avec les matches
dits takata je vais aller chercher
d'autres relations pour faire d'autres
distributions
[Musique]